SORRY -- TO
BAKE YOU WAIT THIS IS A WORK IN
PROGRESS ON THIS CONFERENCE
COMMITTEE --
BUT I WANT REALLY WANT TO THANK
MY CO CHAIR ASSEMBLY MEMBER
HOLDEN IN OUR COLLEAGUES ON THE
CONFERENCE COMMITTEE FOR THEIR
HARD WORK AND COMMITMENT.
WE GET A TRANSPARENT
DELIBERATIVE PROCESS AND WE ALL.
WE APPRECIATE ALL THE PUBLIC
INPUT THAT WE RECEIVED TO
IMPROVE [inaudible]
THE PACKAGE THE MARK UP LANGUAGE
REFLECTING CHANGES POSTED ON THE
CONFERENCE COMMITTEE WEBSITE.
AS I STATED ORDER FOR EVER FIRST
HEARING.
MY GOALS WERE PRETTY
STRAIGHTFORWARD FIRST AND
FOREMOST. TO FIGHT FOR THOSE
THAT WERE DEVASTATED THE TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN FIRES. TO
PREVENT FUTURE WILDFIRES.
FROM CLAIMING NEW VICTIMS
[inaudible]
SECOND PREVENTING RATEPAYERS AND
TAXPAYERS PAYERS FROM BEARING I
DO COSTS.
AND WE LOOK AT THE CONFERENCE
REPORT WE CAN SAVE ADVANCES
THOSE GOALS IN A VERY MEANINGFUL
WAY.
IT ALSO IMPROVES --
WHAT WE'VE IDENTIFIED AS NEEDING
IN OUR LAST HEARING?
MAKE NO MISTAKE ABOUT IT IT'S
NOT PERFECT.
AND LITTLE THAT WE DO A HERE
EVER AS FRANKLY --
BUT WE MAKE REAL PROGRESS WHICH
WILL HELP SAVE COMMUNITIES.
AND PROTECT RATEPAYERS.
WE CAN'T GO BACK IN TIME TO
CHANGE PAST RAT TRAGEDIES.
BUT WE MUST STAND WITH VICTIMS
AND LEARNED FROM MISTAKES OF THE
PAST TAKE REAL STEPS. TO PREVENT
FUTURE WILDFIRES IN IMPLEMENT
BEST PRACTICES GOING FORWARD.
WE CAN ALL AGREE THAT BUSINESS
AS USUAL IN A WORD.
IS UNACCEPTABLE.
CLEARLY UTILITIES IN THE CP YOU
SEE.
NEED TO BE FORCED TO STEP UP.
IT IT SURE THAT THEY'RE MEETING
OUR SAFETY NEEDS BEFORE DISASTER
STRIKES.
IN THIS PACKAGE WILL HELP US
MEET THAT GOAL.
I HAVE BEEN ON A MISSION OF
WILDFIRE RECOVERY PREVENTION AND
MITIGATION ALL YEAR.
THAT WOULD INCLUDE THE BETTER
UTILITY PLANNING A GREATER
ACCOUNTABILITY TO OPERATE THE
GRID.
INCLUDING CHECKING COMPLIANCE
BEFORE THERE'S A FIRE.
THAT'S AN AREA WHERE THE CPU HE
HAS DONE QUITE POORLY REGULATED
UTILITIES IN ENSURING PUBLIC
SAFETY.
STRENGTHENING THE FIRE FIRE
PREVENTION ACTIVITIES SUCH AS
VEGETATION REMOVAL MUTUAL AID
INFRASTRUCTURE MAINTENANCE
UTILITY COMPANY INSPECTIONS
INTEMPERATE SHUT OFF THE POWER
DURING EXTREME WEATHER.
OUR HOLISTIC APPROACH WILL
SAFEGUARD CALIFORNIA AGAINST
FUTURE FIRESTORMS CAUSED BY OUR
GRAND OR OTHER SOURCES.
THIS IS ALSO ABOUT PROTECTING
RATEPAYERS AND COMMUNITIES NOT
JUST HELPING UTILITIES.
IF THE FIT LEGISLATURE FAILS TO
ACT AVOIDABLE FIRES WILL
CONTINUE TO HAPPEN.
FAILURE TO PASS DIED S. B. NINE
รณ ONE WILL JEOPARDIZE RECOVERY
OF VICTIMS PREVENTION MEASURES
THAT ARE SO DESPERATELY NEEDED.
AND REPAIRS WE LEFT HOLDING THE
BAG.
AGAIN THIS PACKAGE IS ABOUT
COMMUNITIES VICTIMS AND
RATEPAYERS [inaudible]
PAST.
PRESENT AND FUTURE.
AND ULTIMATELY WHAT'S BEST FOR
THEM.
AGAIN THANKS TO EVERYONE WHO'S
HELPED CRAFT THIS PROPOSAL IT I
LOOK FORWARD TO IS A SIGN IN THE
CONFERENCE REPORT [inaudible]
THIS EVENING.
SO WE HAVE A CONFERENCE REPORT
--
IT BEFORE US.
I KNOW THIS IS QUICK FOR A LOT
OF PEOPLE THIS IS THE WAY IT IS
THE TIME IS WHAT IT AT IS.
I'D LIKE TO FIND OUT NOW IF I
HAVE A MOTION --
TO APPROVE.
MISTER CHAIR I WOULD --
BE PLEASED TO MAKE THAT --
MOTION.
ABILITY LET ME SAY THIS AS I
MAKE THE MOTION.
OF THIS IS BEEN A AS I'VE SAID
BEFORE VERY CHALLENGING.
PROCESS.
AND TO THE EXTENT THAT.
MANY OF US WERE STILL GRAPPLING
WITH WHAT DIRECTION WE WOULD WE
WERE GOING AND EVEN UP TO TWO
O'CLOCK LAST NIGHT [inaudible]
AND WE HAD TO MOVE.
WHAT'S IN FRONT OF US TODAY
THEIR ELEMENTS IN IT THAT I DID
NOT NECESSARILY [inaudible]
FEEL COMFORTABLE.
BUT I RECOGNIZE THAT WE DO AS
LEGISLATIVE BODY HAVE A
FIDUCIARY RESPONSIBILITY
[inaudible]
THAT.
I'M PREPARED TO STEP FORWARD AND
ASSUMES.
I ALSO BELIEVE THAT IT'S
IMPORTANT. TO NOTE THAT.
THOSE WHO HAVE HAD --
COMMENTS EVEN UP TO OUR LAST
MEETING LAST NIGHT FROM THE RATE
PEER GROUPS [inaudible]
THAT THERE.
CONCERNS AND FRUSTRATIONS WE
TAKE.
THE GREAT --
SERIOUSNESS.
BUT I BELIEVE THAT THIS
[inaudible]
PROPOSAL LISTS REPORT THIS
CONFERENCE REPORT.
ON IN TOTAL.
IS THE RIGHT WAY FOR THIS
LEGISLATURE TO MOVE TO ADDRESS
THE VARIOUS ISSUES THAT ARE
BEFORE US AND SO I WOULD.
SECOND I WOULD MAKE A MOTION TO
APPROVE AN ADOPT.
THIS CONFERENCE REPORT AS
PRESENTED TODAY.
WAIT BEFORE YOU SAY AND I JUST
THINK IT'S WHAT I JUST HEARD
FROM THE LEGISLATIVE --
COMMITTEE SECRETARY.
IF THERE'S A SECOND ON THIS
THERE'S NO FURTHER DISCUSSION
FROM THE DIETS I AM FINE WITH
THAT.
BUT THAT IS THE RULES OF THE
LEGISLATURE I JUST FOUND THAT.
IF SOMEBODY WANTS TO MAKE A A
SECOND THEY STILL CAN BUT THOSE
ARE THE RULES.
THAT SHE'D I DON'T THINK SHE WON
ALL THE WAY THROUGH BUT SHE
WANTS TO NASHIK.
SO THOSE ARE SECOND.
NO I'M IF ALRIGHT SO WE HAVE A
SECOND WE HAVE A MOTION AND
SECOND.
SO GONNA DO IS WE'RE TO TAKE
PUBLIC COMMENT.
GOOD NOT US.
SO WE CAN.
OKAY A WE GOT GOOD.
BOTH WITH. FIVE FOR IT SO.
LOOK IF FOLKS SORRY THAT WE'RE
JUST GET THE RULES AS WE GO HERE
IT'S A ONE OF THOSE THINGS.
SO WITH THIS GOVERNMENT SO. FOR
PURPOSES OF TAKING PUBLIC
COMMENT I WITHDRAW THIS THE THE
MOTION.
SO WHAT WE'D LIKE YEARS --
IF YOU WANT TO COME UP --
STATE YOUR NAME YOUR
ORGANIZATION AND WHETHER YOU
SUPPORT.
WHETHER YOU SUPPORT THE PROPOSAL
OR NOT.
I THINK THAT'S WHERE WE'RE AT
FROM RIGHT THERE.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS CAN'T COUNT
WITH SENATOR GAS ELECTRIC --
AS UTILITY WITH NOT A SINGLE
PENNY OF OUTSTANDING LIABILITY
AND INDUSTRY LEADING PRACTICES
AND PROGRAMS IN PLACE WE VIEW
THIS.
LANGUAGE ALTHOUGH WE HAVEN'T
SEEN THE FINAL LANGUAGE I'M NOT
SURE ON THE ISSUE WHAT WHAT IT
IS THAT'S IN THE CONFERENCE
REPORT.
BUT WE WE ARE GREATLY CONCERNED
WITH WHAT'S IN HERE WE THINK
THIS TAKES A STEP BACKWARDS FROM
YESTERDAY --
AND POSSIBLY A STEP BACKWARDS
FROM WHAT SOME EXISTING LOT
TODAY.
WE HAVE GREAT UNCERTAINTY ON
WHAT THE FINANCIAL MARKETS HOW
THEY WILL VIEW THIS.
I WAS WE WERE NOTED IN JULY.
THAT WE WERE LOOKING AT
DOWNGRADES OF THREE NOTCHES AT
THE UTILITY ONE NOTCH AT THE
PARENT COMPANY.
IF ACTION WASN'T TAKEN BY THIS
FRIDAY.
THERE'S AN ISSUE THAT YOU KNOW
INSERTED SORRY --
THE SCOUTS IT'S YOUR NAME WITH
THE SUPPORT THE PROGRAM OR NOT
KNOWS THE RULES.
LEADS TO GREATER UNCERTAINTY
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIRMAN --
MEMBERS THE COMMITTEE MICHAEL
SAW CALIFORNIA MANUFACTURING
TECHNOLOGY ASSOCIATION IN IF I
MIGHT ASK A QUESTION.
WE HAVEN'T ACTUALLY SEEN THE
REPORT THAT YOU'RE GONNA BE
VOTING ON SO JUST TO BE CLEAR
WERE NOT ALLOWED TO MAKE ANY
PUBLIC COMMENTS.
REGARDING DRAFTS WE'VE SEEN
PREVIOUSLY OR HIGH WE'RE
ANYTHING HERE LOOK AT MICHAEL.
CAN'T YOU GET WHAT WHAT WE'RE
GONNA DO IS WE'RE GONNA GO BACK.
TO CHIU CO CHAIR AND I DECIDED
JUST NOW WE'RE WE'RE FINDING OUT
THESE RULES AT THE LAST MINUTE
WE'RE GONNA GO BACK AND DO WHAT
WE'VE DONE FROM THE BEGINNING.
WE'RE GONNA GIVE EVERYBODY A
MINUTE HAVE TAUGHT IF IT'S GONNA
BE A MINUTE AND YOU'RE DONE.
AND I'M SORRY BUT WE GOT A CLOCK
THAT WERE.
NOT WE WE'VE GOT --
TO GO TO CAN'T YOU'VE GOT THIRTY
SECONDS.
THIS SONG SO SPECIFICALLY THE
LANGUAGE NOW SAYS THAT WE WILL
GO THROUGH A REASONABLE S.
REVIEW AND AFTER THAT IS DONE WE
MAY RECOVER.
EXISTING LAW PROVIDES WE THINK
GREATER CERTAINTY THAT IF YOU GO
THROUGH A REGIONAL OFFICE
REASONABLENESS.
YOU GET RECOVERY THIS GETS A
SECOND BITE AT THE APPLE THIS
VERSION ALSO REMOVES ANY
LANGUAGE BY RELATING TO
FINANCIAL STATUS SUNDAY'S
VERSION HAD ONE APPROACH
YESTERDAY'S VERSION HAVE
ANOTHER.
ON ACCOUNT OF STATUS TEST.
THIS CURRENT VERSION AS WE
UNDERSTAND IT NOT HAVING LOOKED
AT WHAT WAS HANDED OUT HERE --
REMOVES BULLSHIT.
I THINK IT IS OUR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS EQUITY MICHAEL SAW
CALIFORNIA MANUFACTURES AND
TECHNOLOGY ASSOCIATION I
APPRECIATE WORK.
RECONSIDERATION ON THE COMMENTS
--
OF SPECIFICALLY LIKE TO DRAW
ATTENTION --
TO THE ARE AND I WITH A TIME
STAMP OF THREE TWELVE PM TODAY
--
LITTLE SEE IN SECTION TWENTY
SEVEN SAYS ELECTRIC CORPORATION
MAY APPLY FOR FINANCING OR
PURSUANT. TO ARTICLE FIVE POINT
EIGHT CHAPTER FOR THE AMOUNT
EXPENSES ALLOCATE TO THE REPAIR
AS JUST AND REASONABLE OR AS
WELL DISALLOWED FOR RECOVERY.
BUT EXCEEDING THE AMOUNT
DETERMINED PURSUANT TO
SUBSECTION BE --
ALSO I WOULD REFER TO A BELIEVES
REFER TO AS A STRESS TEST.
IT'S VERY DIFFICULT TO SEE THAT
NOT THEY ALLOWED ANY WHEN
THEY'RE THAT WOMEN OR BALLOTS
THAT WERE DISALLOWED FOR SOME
OTHER REASON INCLUDING
POTENTIALLY THE NEGLIGENCE OR
IMPRUDENCE.
OF THE UTILITY --
BEING ALLOWED TO BE PUT BACK ON
THE RATE PAYERS AND FOR THAT
REASON AND OTHERS THAT WE MAY
HAVE YET TO UNCOVER --
WE DO YOU OPPOSE THIS MOTION
THINKS.
MICHAEL BOGOTA ARE ON BEHALF OF
THE AGRICULTURAL ENERGY
CONSUMERS ASSOCIATION ALL SHARE
THE SAME CONCERNS THAT MISTER.
CHARGES SHARED WITH THE
COMMITTEE WE TO DO NOT BELIEVE
THIS GOES ANYWHERE NEAR FAR
ENOUGH TO PROTECT RATEPAYERS.
EVEN WHEN THE UTILITIES
NEGLIGENT OUR COMPANIES WHO HAD
NOTHING TO DO WITH THERE BEING
NEGLIGENT ARE GOING TO BE ON THE
HOOK.
POTENTIALLY BILLIONS OF DOLLARS
OF LIABILITY AND THAT'S JUST
FRANKLY NOT FAIR OR RIGHT OR
JUST I THINK AS YOU HEARD FROM
SOME OF THE OTHER UTILITIES AND
WE'LL HEAR FROM THE REST OF
UTILITIES.
THEY DON'T THINK IT'S FAIR AND
JUST EITHER THANK YOU.
GERMAN WAS WITH HUNTERS WITH THE
WESTERN SYNCHROTRON ASSOCIATION
ECHOING THE COMMENTS FROM MY
COLLEAGUE FROM C. MTA AND MISTER
BOOK ADORO.
OF THIS IS JUST PROTECTING ONE
BAD ACTOR LET'S BE HONEST WE
OPPOSE THE PROPOSAL.
DANIEL BROUGHT ON BEHALF OF
SIERRA CLUB CALIFORNIA AND ARE
MORE THAN. FOUR HUNDRED THOUSAND
MEMBERS AND SUPPORTERS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
WE ARE UNFORTUNATELY OPPOSED TO
THE MOST RECENT THING THAT WE'VE
SEEN BECAUSE OF THE FOREST
MANAGEMENT ASPECTS OF THE BELT.
LIKE MANY OF YOU WE ARE VERY
SUPPORT OF HARDENING OF HOMES.
AND ASK FUNDS DIRECTED TOWARDS A
HARDENING OF HOMES AND TOWARDS
APPROPRIATE MANAGING OUR BIT.
TREATMENT AND THE URBAN WILDLAND
INTERFACE SCIENCE PROVES THESE
TO BE THE MOST EFFECTIVE.
DEFENSE MECHANISMS TO WILDFIRE
AS WRITTEN THIS BILL WOULD
REMOVE REASOABLE REGULATIONS
AND OVERSIGHT IN THE FORM OF
TIMBER HARVEST PLANS FOR THREE
HUNDRED ACRE PLOTS.
AND FOR THE CONSTRUCTION OF SIX
HUNDRED FOOT LONG ROUTES
ADDITIONALLY THE SPELL INHIBITS
OVERSIGHT AND BY GRANTING
SEQUENCE EXEMPTIONS WITHOUT
SUFFICIENT OVERSIGHT SPEW
TREATMENT AND MANAGEMENT
ACTIVITIES.
I WILL LIKELY NOT ACHIEVE THEIR
DESIRED OUTCOMES ARE WORSE COULD
HARM FOREST ECOSYSTEMS AND
WATERWAYS.
WE PROVIDED A MORE DETAILED
VERSION OF THE FAMILY VERY MUCH
LIKE SPEAKER.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MARK
FRIENDSTER MAKER FOR THE NATURE
CONSERVANCY WE SUPPORT THIS
COMPREHENSIVE PACKAGE BECAUSE WE
NEED TO FOCUS ON ECOLOGICAL WE
BUT SOUND RESTORATION OF OUR
FOREST BECAUSE THE STATUS QUO AS
WE ARE EXPERIENCING WILL MEAN
THE ELIMINATION OF OUR FORESTS.
WE'RE ALSO SUPPORT OF THE FACT
THIS PACKAGE PROVIDES FUNDING OF
THE GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTION
FUND.
THAT WE NEED THESE INVESTMENTS
TO BE INVESTED IN ECOLOGICALLY
SOUND FOREST MANAGEMENT.
WE APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
COMMENT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
GOOD EVENING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE LARA KNOW AND
HEY JACK ON BEHALF OF VARIOUS
AGRICULTURAL TRADE ASSOCIATIONS
HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
AND AS I SAID BEFORE RATE PAYERS
PAY ON THE FRONT AND FOR THESE
WILD FIRE SAFETY PLANS FOR AT
THE COST OF HARDENING THE
SYSTEM.
FOR THE RATE OF RETURN FOR THE
COMMERCIAL INSURANCE AND ARE
PAYING ON THE BACKEND AND NOW
UNDER THIS PLAN I DON'T SEE ANY
CHANGES IN THAT AND WE ACTUALLY
SEE THAT IN TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN WE MAY BE ON THE HOOK
FOR EVEN.
SOME CASES WHERE THE UTILITY
ACTED NEGLIGENTLY AND SO THAT'S
INCREDIBLY CONCERNING TO US --
SO FOR THESE REASONS WE HAVE TO
OPPOSE.
CHAIRPERSON SAN MEMBERS OF
COMMITTEE TRACY HANSON HERE ON
BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA FIRE CHIEFS
ASSOCIATION PART DISTRICTS
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA AND
THE METROPOLITAN PURCHASE
ASSOCIATION.
WE APPRECIATE THE MONUMENTAL
TASK THAT THIS COMMITTEE HAS HAD
TO UNDERTAKE AND A VERY TIGHT
TIMELINE --
WE APPRECIATE VERY MUCH THE
FOLK.
FIRE PREVENTION PLANNING IN
COLLABORATION WITH THE UTILITIES
ON THE SUBJECT AT HAND.
AND WE ALSO DEEPLY APPRECIATE
THE INSERTION OF THE LANGUAGE
AND INVESTMENT IN MUTUAL AID
SYSTEM AND PROVIDING FOR AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR PRE POSITIONING.
AND ATTACKED THESE FIRES EARLY
AND KEEP THEM AS SMALL AS
POSSIBLE SO FOR THOSE REASONS WE
SUPPORT THE PACKAGE AS PRESENTED
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NICK
SPEAKER.
PATRICK WELL TO THE CALIFORNIA
MUNICIPAL UTILITIES ASSOCIATION
WE DON'T HAVE A POSITION ON THE
CONFERENCE BILL BUT LAST NIGHT
IDENTIFIED IN ISSUE.
I WITH THE PROVISION RELATIVE TO
OVERRIDING THE DISCRETION OF OUR
GOVERNING OUR MEMBERS GOVERNING
BOARDS WE WORKED WITH STAFF IN
YOUR COMMITTEE IN WANTED TO
THINK -- FOR
THEM FOR THAT WORK OVER THE PAST
NIGHT AND I THINK THAT ISSUE HAS
BEEN RESOLVED SO THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
THANK YOU NEXT SPEAKER
[inaudible]
YES.
CHAIRMAN HOLDEN.
CHAIRMAN DIED MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE ON CAROLINE CHOI WITH
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA EDISON --
MY COMMENTS ARE SPECIFIC TO THE
ARE AND THAT WAS RELEASED AT
THREE TWELVE THIS AFTERNOON.
AND SINCE WE HAVEN'T SEEN THE
DRAFT THAT YOU MAY BE VOTING ON
TODAY SO WE APPRECIATE THE WORK
THAT'S GONE GONE INTO THIS BILL
TO ADDRESS WHILE FIRE SAFETY IN
THE STATE OF PARTICULARLY AROUND
THE LOFT OUR MANAGEMENT OF THE
UTILITIES --
WE ALSO APPRECIATE TERM HOLDINGS
REMARKS LAST NIGHT IN TERMS OF
WANTING TO WRITE CHAIR CLARITY
TO THAT P. YOU SEE WITH RESPECT
TO COST RECOVERY LENNY TONY SEEK
THAT -- FOR
COSTS AFTER FIRES OCCUR WE
BELIEVE THAT CLARITY HAS NOT
BEEN PROVIDED IN THIS ARE AND
THE SHALL TO MAYBE IS ONE BUT WE
ALSO BELIEVE THAT --
PRESIDENT PICKER SPECIFICALLY
ASK FOR CLARITY TO PORTION COSTS
AND THAT IS ALSO NOT
SPECIFICALLY ADDRESSED IN THIS
DRAFT -- SO
WE JUST WANT TO LET YOU KNOW OF
OUR CONCERNS WITH RESPECT TO
THAT THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
SPEAKER CULTURES AND MEMBERS
PRESSMAN YANNI ON BEHALF
CALIFORNIA LARGE ENERGY
CONSUMERS --
THIS HAS BEEN AN EXTRAORDINARILY
FRUSTRATING --
PROCESS FOR ASSN WITH ALL DUE
RESPECT YOU KNOW I DON'T FEEL
THAT IT'S BEEN OPEN AND
TRANSPARENT I UNDERSTAND IS PART
ONE OF THE MOST DIFFICULT THINGS
YOU HAVE TO DEAL WITH.
BUT THE ITEMS THAT HAVE BEEN
INCLUDED IN THE BILL THAT
APPEARED TO POINT TOWARDS RAY
FAIR PROTECTION SEEM TO BE
WINDOW DRESSING AND THIS SEEMS
TO BE GOING BACKWARDS.
AND NOT PROTECTING RATEPAYERS --
I REALLY HAVE TO SAY I HAVE NOT
HEARD ANY NEGATIVE COMMENTS THAT
I DISAGREED WITH --
FOR THE FOLKS THAT WERE IN FRONT
OF ME -- AND
WITH THAT BEING SAID I I THINK.
HERE INVERSE CONDEMNATION SHOULD
BE SOMETHING THAT THAT THE
LEGISLATURE LOOKS AT AS WELL I
THINK WE'LL BE.
MOVING DOWN THAT PATH AS WELL.
THANK YOU FOR THE FOR THE
UPCOMING THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT SPEAKER POLICE MISTER
CHAIRMAN THE MEMBER SCOTT WHAT
SHOULD BE AT THE CALIFORNIA
COALITION OF UTILITY EMPLOYEES
--
THERE'S A LOT OF GOOD THINGS IN
THIS CONFERENCE COMMITTEE REPORT
[inaudible]
WE HOPE THERE'S ENOUGH TO
PROTECT VICTIMS.
BOB BUT IT WITH THAT WE DO
SINCERELY APPRECIATE ALL THE
WORK THAT ALL THE COUNTRIES IN
YOUR STAFF PUT INTO THIS AND SO
WE THANK YOU FOR THAT.
JULIE ON ASKING BALL ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA BIOMASS ENERGY
ALLIANCE WHO WANT TO THANK YOU
ACTUALLY FOR THE NOD --
IN THIS BILL --
TOWARD BIOMASS AND SEEK IN AND
USING THIS IS THIS
INFRASTRUCTURE AS A TOOL TO HELP
BETTER MANAGE YOU KNOW FOREST OF
RESOURCES --
BUT WE DO WANT YOU TO PUT IT
BEFORE IT YOU ON NOTICE THAT
WE'RE NOT DONE WE HAVEN'T DONE
ENOUGH IN THIS WE'VE ONLY REALLY
JUST PICKED AWAY AT A MUCH
LARGER SOLUTION THAT IS THAT
THAT COULD BE DONE IN THIS BILL.
AND IF NOT THIS BILL WE'D LIKE
YOUR COMMITMENT TO GET IT DONE
AND FUTURE LEGISLATURE'S
THINKING.
I CONFEREES DARBY KERN AND WENT
THAT CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION ON BEHALF OF THE
LEAGUE OF CALIFORNIA CITIES AND
URBAN COUNTIES OF CALIFORNIA WE
SUPPORT AND APPRECIATE THE WORK
YOU'VE DONE.
AND APPRECIATE THE PACKAGE
TODAY.
PATRICK MCCALLUM FROM UP FROM
THE ASHES BEHALF OF OUR BROAD
COALITION.
OF VICTIMS BOTH IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA AND IN NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA.
BEHALF OF OUR BROAD COALITION
THAT INCLUDE THE CITIES AND
COUNTIES THE CONSUMER ATTORNEYS
AND OUR INSURANCE INDUSTRY.
WE SUPPORT THIS COMPREHENSIVE
PACKAGE DO YOU COME UP WITH.
WE WANT TO THANK EACH ONE OF YOU
INDIVIDUALLY COLLECTIVELY AS A
COMMITTEE.
THIS IS TOUGH COMPLEX ISSUES
WITH BIG CHANGES BUT CALIFORNIA
VICTIMS WILL BE BETTER.
CALIFORNIA WILL BE SAFER AS A
STATE FOR BOTH.
FIRE YOU'VE BEEN THIS BALANCE
BETWEEN RATEPAYERS IN PROTECTING
THE RATEPAYERS.
MISS RAY S. YOU PUT PROVISIONS
IN THEIR RATE PAYERS ARE
PROTECTED.
AND WE PROVIDED SOME PROVISIONS
TO MAKE SURE OUR UTILITIES ARE
FINANCIALLY STABLE TO IN THE
FUTURE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH VERY MUCH
FOR YOUR HARD WORK.
THANK YOU XP HER.
GOOD EVENING STACEY HE ORAL
COUNTY REPRESENTATIVES OF
CALIFORNIA REPRESENTING THIRTY
FIVE RURAL COUNTIES STATEWIDE.
WE'RE WE LIKE THEY WERE VERY
SUPPORTIVE OF THE DIRECTION OF
THE PACKAGE ESPECIALLY WITH
RESPECT TO FOREST IN VEGETATION
MANAGEMENT FUELS TREATMENT.
THAT'S A TOP PRIORITY FIRST YEAR
SEE MEMBER COUNTIES AND IT'S
SOMETHING THAT WE FEEL CAN'T
WAIT ANY LONGER SO WE APPRECIATE
THE ATTENTION TO THAT ISSUE.
AND I WILL LOOK FORWARD TO
SEEING THE FINAL PACKAGE AND
FINAL LANGUAGE AS IT COMES OUT
THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
TEARS MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
CHRISTY BAUM ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA PROFESSIONAL
FIREFIGHTERS.
HERE'S A WHERE THE PACKAGE
RETIRED MEMBER MANY MEMBERS OF
THIS COMMITTEE TALK ABOUT THESE
CATASTROPHIC WILDFIRES.
THE BY MEMBERS OF IT ON THE
FRONT LINES DAY AFTER DAY AFTER
DAY BATTLING.
AND APPRECIATE THE FACT THAT
YOU.
ARE SEEKING SOLUTIONS THAT IN
THE SHORT TERM AND LONG TERM.
A BEND THE CURVE ON THESE TYPES
OF CATASTROPHES AND SO THAT WE
DON'T FACE THEM YEAR AFTER YEAR
AND ESCALATED FASHION SO
APPRECIATE THE WORK.
SPORT PACKAGE.
CHAIRS AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE LEON TRACK NOW BEHALF
OF CONSUMER ATTORNEYS OF
CALIFORNIA WHERE IN SUPPORT OF
THE HARD WORK OF THE CONFERENCE
COMMITTEE ON THE PACKAGE
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
PAUL MASON PACIFIC FOREST TRUST
I DO OBJECT WE WANT TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE FOR THE INCLUSION OF
THE ONGOING FUNDING.
FOR FOREST MANAGEMENT PRESCRIBED
FIRE OR FIRE MANAGEMENT IN
GENERAL I DO THINK WE NEED TO DO
SOME FOLLOW UP ON THAT NEXT YEAR
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE DOING
VEGETATION MANAGEMENT.
WOULD THEN A THOUGHTFUL WAY
THAT'S ACHIEVING LONG TERM
ECOLOGICAL GOALS BUT WE
APPRECIATE THAT INCLUSION SO WE
CAN ACTUALLY PLAN THESE THINGS
YEAR OVER YEAR THANK YOU
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MARK TONY TURNED THE UTILITY
REFORM NETWORK WE STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BAILOUT FOR P.
TIERNEY.
PARTICULARLY BECAUSE THE THOUGHT
THAT CAP.
ON HOW MUCH HE DID ME PAYS FOR
FIRE DAMAGE AND NO CATCH FOUR
HOW MUCH RATE PAYERS PAY.
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS AT STAKE
SHOULD NOT BE DECIDED IN SUCH A
RUSH PROCESS.
THIS SECURITIZATION SPREADING
OUT THE COST FOR RATEPAYERS CAN
ALSO BE DONE FIRST SHAREHOLDERS
WE SHOULD BE LOOKING AT HOW WE
CAN SPREAD OUT THE COST NOT JUST
FOR RATEPAYERS.
BUT FOR SHAREHOLDERS TO THERE
ARE SO MANY THINGS THAT ARE
PROBLEMATIC ABOUT THIS BILL WE
DON'T EVEN KNOW THE DIFFERENT
VISION OF THE TUB FIRE THAT OF
THE MATERIAL.
AND FIVE SECONDS PLEASE
[inaudible]
VOTE NO.
OSN S. B. [inaudible]
NINE OH ONE THANK YOU
[inaudible]
OKAY.
THERE BEING NO MORE A PUBLIC
SPEAKERS OUT.
TURN -- TO
THIS MEANT THAT TO CAN BE
EXPLAINED WHAT'S GOING ON WITH
THE TALKS YEAH I JUST WANT TO
CLARIFY FOR YOU PLEASE IF THERE
ARE TO OUR ENDS FLOATING OUT
THERE.
THERE IS ONE THAT WAS POSTED ON
THE WEBSITE AT THREE TWELVE
TODAY THAT WE HAD JUST GOTTEN
BACK FROM COUNSEL THAT IS THE
SAME DOCUMENT THAT WAS JUST
HANDED OUT.
THAT IS NUMBER ONE EIGHT TWO
ZERO ONE EIGHT ONE THE
DIFFERENCE IS WE GOT THE
DOCUMENT OUT BACK AT YOU SEE
THREE TWELVE WE MADE AT ITS TO
THAT WE PUT THAT MARK UP ON THE
WEBSITE.
AND THEN COUNSEL MADE THE
CHANGES AND THE OTHER DOCUMENT
THAT WAS DISTRIBUTED.
ONE EIGHT TWO ZERO ONE EIGHT ONE
REFLECTS THE DOCUMENT THERE
VOTING ON BUT THE CONTENT OF
THOSE ARE THE SAME.
AND BOTH WILL BE PUT UP ON THE
WEBSITE [inaudible]
OKAY.
WE CAN HAVE COMMITMENT FOR US TO
CHAIR COMMITTEE MEMBERS
ATMOSPHERE LIKE TO MAKE A MOTION
ON PAGE THIRTY FIVE SECTION.
TWENTY SIX FORTY FIVE POINT ONE
A ON THE THIRD LINE.
I BELIEVE THAT SHOULD BE THE
COMMISSION SHALL NOT THE
COMMISSION MAY ALLOW COST
RECOVERY.
IT WOULD TAKE OF THAT.
PAGE.
THIRTY FIVE THEY SAID YOU HAVE
THE ABILITY [inaudible]
I'D SAY.
SHE IS A SECOND THERE'S A MOTION
IS OUR SECOND [inaudible]
OKAY.
WE HAVE A MOTION A SECOND
[inaudible]
DISCUSSION.
THE MOTION IS ON AN AMENDMENT ON
THE AMP AMENDING THIS SECTION
BECAUSE I I'LL JUST BE VERY
CLEAR I'M NOT SUPPORTING.
ANY CHANGES AT THIS POINT.
LARA AND AND IF YOU VOTE ON IT
YOU VOTE ON IT.
BUT I I SHARED WITH.
WITH YOU EARLIER DEBT.
AND I AND I UNDERSTAND THE LOGIC
BEHIND YOUR OF YOUR REQUEST.
AND YOUR MOTION --
SO BUT I WILL NOT [inaudible]
A PROPOSAL.
THAT MAKES THAT CHANGE AT THIS
THAT THE STE.
I ALSO WILL NOT BE SUPPORTING
THAT THERE'S BEEN LOTS OF
DISCUSSION THERE'S BEEN LOTS OF
REGARDING THE LANGUAGE AND IF
GOD AMENDMENT IS TAKEN AT THIS
LIGHT LATE OUR I WILL NOT
SUPPORT THIS.
HE OTHER DISCUSSION YEAH I
THOUGHT I'D LIKE OTHER JUST
POSIT THAT.
YOU NO GIVEN ALL THE CONDITIONS
HERE -- IT
SHOULDN'T REALLY MAKE A
DIFFERENCE BECAUSE YOU CAN FIX
OR EXCLUDE ANYTHING USING THE
VARIOUS FACTORS THAT ARE THERE
[inaudible]
SO -- I I
KNOW WE'RE HAVING A BIG DISPUTE
ABOUT IT AT THIS TIME I AT THIS
HOUR.
AND I'M NOT PARTICULARLY HAPPY
WITH THIS WHOLE PROCESS BUT I
THINK AT THIS POINT IN TIME --
IT MAY I WAS.
YOU KNOW YOU SAY --
IS A MORE FLEXIBLE APPROACH AND
SO I WILL I WILL NOT SUPPORT THE
CHANGE IN THE MEMBER BUT I WOULD
LIKE TO EMPHASIZE.
THAT BECAUSE THERE ARE A NUMBER
OF DIFFERENT FACTORS THAT CAN BE
CONSIDERED.
THIS DOES IN FACT GIVE THE
DETERMINING BODY AN OPPORTUNITY
TO MAKE VALUE JUDGMENTS --
THAT --
WHETHER YOU USE THE WORD SHALL
OR USE THE WORD MAY IF YOU HAVE
THE WORD SHALL.
AND IT'S AS WELL THEY HAVE TO DO
IT IF THEY FIND THESE TWELVE
FACTORS.
THEY COULD EASILY SAY WELL WE
DON'T REALLY WANT TO DO THAT SO
WE'RE NOT GONNA FIND IN THOSE
TWELVE FACTOR SO I'M NOT SURE
YOU REALLY ACCOMPLISHING.
WHAT YOU WANT HERE THAT'S MY
LAWYER HAPPENED FOR YOU KNOW
THIS JOB DOESN'T PAY ENOUGH ON
THE HOURLY RATE THAT A LAWYER
WOULD CHARGE SO?
DON'T HOLD ME TO THAT LEGAL
ANALYSIS BALUCHISTAN OFF THE TOP
MY AND MISTER CHAIR IF I CAN
JUST SPEAK TO IT.
RIGHT FROM THE VERY BEGINNING
THE GOAL OF THIS WAS TO PROVIDE
[inaudible]
SOME LEVEL.
OF CERTAINTY WITHOUT CREATING A
MORAL HAZARD.
AND WHILE I APPRECIATE ALL THE
WORK THAT IS BEING DONE THIS
LANGUAGE THAT WE GOT CAME TO US.
JUST MINUTES BEFORE THE
COMMITTEE IN FACT IS AS WE KNOW
PEOPLE ARE COMING IN AND
DROPPING LANGUAGE OFF NOW.
WE LIKE TO SPEAK OF A
TRANSPARENT PROCESS --
BUT AS A COMMITTEE NOT ONE TIME
HAVE WE EVER HAD A TRUE MARK UP
SESSION ON THIS TO FIND OUT
WHETHER THIS COMMITTEE A
MAJORITY OF THIS COMMITTEE
ACTUALLY APPROVE THE LANGUAGE
BEFORE US.
THE TRUTH IS THIS LANGUAGE WAS
DONE IN A BACK ROOM.
MY GUESS IS THIS LANGUAGE WAS
DONE BY STAFF WITHOUT MEMBER
IMPORT OR VERY LITTLE MEMBER
INPUT ON WHAT WAS BEFORE US THAT
IS INCREDIBLY FRUSTRATING I
GOTTA TELL YOU.
AS AN ELECTED OFFICIAL SOMEBODY
THAT SPENT.
AN ENTIRE OPEC ALMOST TO A LIFE
FOR ME TO BE ABLE TO RUN FOR
OFFICE TO CAMPAIGN TO COME UP
HERE AND I THINK THAT ON ELECTED
INDIVIDUALS ARE RIDING THIS
WITHOUT ANY ABILITY FOR US TO BE
ABLE TO OPINE.
AND THIS THE FIRST TIME I'VE
OFFERED UP LANGUAGE AND IT'S ONE
WORD FROM MAY. TO SHALL THAT
PROVIDES HIGHER LEVEL OF
CERTAINTY BEFORE THIS GETS THE
P. YOU SEE AND APPRECIATE A VOTE
ON THIS AMENDMENT [inaudible]
IT'S REYES.
THERE'S NO QUESTION THAT STAFF
PREPARED THE FIRST DRAFT AND IT
WAS.
REFERRED TO AS THE STAFF DRAFT.
I TOOK THE TIME TO GO THROUGH
EVERY SINGLE PAGE.
I DON'T KNOW OF ANYBODY ELSE DID
I WANT TO EVERY SINGLE PAGE IN
THE DRAFT AND I MADE MY
COMMENTS.
SOME WERE INCLUDED SOME OR NOT
BUT WHAT WE HAVE HERE.
INCLUDING THE VERY WORD THAT YOU
WANT TO CHANGE IS SOMETHING THAT
WAS RECOMMENDED.
AFTER MY REVIEW [inaudible]
IT'S A I'M.
I THINK THAT WHAT WE HAVE TO
HAVE IS WE HAVE TO HAVE.
THREE ASSEMBLY MEMBERS FIRST
YOU'VE GOT ASSEMBLY MEMBER VOTE.
IS THE IS THAT ACCURATE I'M A
DIFFERENCE FOR YOU ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS OF THREE SENATORS.
SO A YOU PUT UP THE MOST AYE I
DISLIKE. TO SEE IF THERE'S THREE
VOTES ON THE ASSEMBLY BEFORE WE
GO ANY FURTHER.
THERE'S NOT ABOUT TO PUT MY
MEMBERS THROUGH YEAH THROUGH
THROUGH THAT.
I I JUST WANT I JUST WANT TO SAY
--
WITH THAT [inaudible]
OKAY.
SO WE HAVE WE HAVE TO VOTE ON
THE MOTION IS THE RETURN HOME
[inaudible]
OKAY.
CALL THE ROLL PLEASE
[inaudible]
SENATOR STOTT [inaudible]
NO [inaudible]
NO.
SENATOR CANNELLA BY CANNELLA AYE
SENATOR WESO [inaudible]
SENATOR JACKSON [inaudible]
SENATOR STONE.
SENATOR STONE AYE.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER HOLDEN.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER HOLDEN NO
[inaudible]
ASSEMBLYMEMBER DOLLY.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER MAYES AYE AYE.
SO YOU REYES I ASSEMBLY MEMBER
A. S..
SEMI MEMORY IS KNOW ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WOULD.
SEMI MEMBER WOULD NOW.
MOTION FAILS.
AYE I DID JUST FOR THE RECORD.
I I WORKED HARD OVER THE LAST
FIVE DAYS TO GET WHAT --
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MAYES WAS
PROPOSING HERE SOMETIMES A
POLITICS YOU GET WHAT YEAH.
YOU KNOW WHAT.
OTHER TIMES IT DON'T WE RAN OUT
THE CLOCK.
I THINK WHAT WE HAVE HERE BEFORE
US.
REPRESENTS THE BEST THAT WE
COULD DO.
AS A COMMITTEE TO AS A COMMITTEE
TODAY.
AND WELL I DISAPPOINTED ABOUT
THAT ONE SITUATION I LOOK AT THE
WHOLE PACKAGE.
IT MAY BE A LITTLE BIT
ENCOURAGING THAT THE RATE PAYERS
AND UTILITIES --
HAVE BOTH HAVE A PROBLEM WITH
THIS -- SO --
IT IS WHAT IT IS --
WE'VE GOTTA MOVE ON IT WILL HAVE
OPPORTUNITIES --
AS WE DO HERE IN BOTH OF OUR
HOUSES TO ADVANCED POLICIES IN
THE FUTURE IF --
THE MEMBERS BELIEVE THAT THAT'S
THE BEST WAY OF GOING.
SO WITH THAT --
I'M LOOKING FOR A MOTION ON THE
PLAN.
AS CHAIR OF ITS COMMITTEE
REPORTS USE ME.
SURE I WOULD MOVE ADOPTION OF
THE CONFERENCE COMMITTEE REPORT.
WE HAVE SECOND.
CALL THE ROLL.
THAT THE CONFERENCE COMMITTEE
REPORT ON SB NINE I WON BE
ADOPTED AND FURTHER AMENDED
[inaudible]
SENATOR STOTT.
SENATOR DODD AYE [inaudible]
SENATOR CANNELLA [inaudible]
SENATOR HUESO [inaudible]
SENATOR JACKSON.
SENATOR JACKSON AYE SENATOR
STONE.
SENATOR STONE I ASSEMBLY MEMBER
HOLDEN.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER HOLDEN AYE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER DONNIE DOT
DOLLY.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER DOLLY I ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MAYES.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RANTS ON
ASSEMBLY MEMORY AS I ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WHAT.
SEMI MEMBER WOULD I MOTION
PASSES [inaudible]
THAT'S THAT.
GREEN VOTES OUT OF THE SENATE
FOR VOTES OUT OF THE ASSEMBLY
THAT MOTION PASSES.
AND WE GOT TO SIGN THE REPORT.
PLEASE HANG ON
NO I THINK
JUSTICE WHICH IS.
LEARN THE MEANING.
I THINK THEY KNOW [inaudible]
WHO CARES
WITH ALL THE
SIGNATURES ON THE CONFERENCE
REPORT THIS MEETING IS ADJOURNED